what up what up what up what up what up
how you doing how you livin how you
feelin it is Sims and a little of gold
coming to the stage how you doing good
how are you I'm great
are you great yeah good it's here you
know what it is Monday whoa big
offseason baby I love the offseason it's
great I want to say first and foremost
thank you to the people from around the
world that bought your sim 70 shirt
thank you very much we're talking about
Latin America we're talking about Europe
we're talking about England we're
shipping some to Brazil yes yes you know
what else happened that was really funny
right I told Fender ik we have another
shirt in the store and he's like they're
not gonna find it and I said no they're
gonna find it guys we now have a whoa
big offseason shirt it is available now
it's the one that I was excited about
sim 70 we've been working on for a long
time yeah but I don't think there's a
shirt that represents us better than one
big offseason yeah are we gonna have
anything else on there with the world bi
t dot ly / big offseason you haven't
even seen it yet I haven't seen that one
no I have not seen that version of the
t-shirt yeah I'm gonna go to her right
now bi t off C's I'm telling you that
they found ourselves of listeners yes
went in and somehow found the shirt that
wasn't even listed this is the whoa big
offseason shirt I like that you're gonna
put some selection actually that is when
the sim 70 here I do too
yeah whoa big offseason cool shirt it is
a cool shirt it is and so what big
offseason shirts are now available
perfect for this summer perfect for this
offseason bi t dot ly / big offseason or
if you follow us on Sims aleph go
Twitter Instagram we're gonna post the
link well put it on the YouTube as well
a little bit later on the show we caught
out with Grunk on the set of a tide
commercial yeah I give a little
explanation beforehand I kind of tried
to mess with Gronk and it kind of worked
a little bit
I told him that all of my questions were
fan questions and that way he was a lot
more likely to answer yeah he told us
what he would name his firstborn son if
he had one mmm so all that's coming up
in the Crockett Maximus can't tell you
he got to stick around for the interview
looks like it Maximus kind of guy well
you know one thing that upset me this
weekend I mean put up the polls right
for our mascot battle put one on Twitter
who won Simms the Niner or left go the
Steeler put it on Instagram who won
Simms the the Niner left go the Steeler
I just think people are voting for you
without listening whoa I just think
they're voting for you that's all right
don't worry about it man I'm beating you
in these argument the amount of people
that used words and message me and said
left code definitely got the W it was
like 9 to 1 but in terms of just
clicking votes right you won oh okay so
you're out of your 10 best friends nine
of them Cody MDO said hey do you want to
know you won nope did not don't they
just like you more I think it's cuz your
name's first I think if I wrote left ko
or sin I think my arguments are more
compelling I think that's really what
the kind of you couldn't matter you lost
they own the drive and determination of
a 49er and his gold on the horizon and
what he was doing for that leaving his
family and then I sharpen my instrument
to hurt hurt you in the fight and you
were just trying to hit me with a big
sledgehammer and it's hard I if Phil
doesn't come on the podcast on Wednesday
yeah I'm really upset yeah I think if
Phil doesn't come on the podcast we're
fining him or we should let more numbers
of his cell phone out when we leave that
voicemail be checking the YouTube yeah
it'll be comment like someone wrote I
heard a three and then someone responds
like I heard it too we're getting closer
it starts with the two it ends of the
three I'll tell feels really yeah
because I think we've let the 201 from
the 201 area what research the other
nine million possibilities the - oh my
gosh you're crazy yeah but we're gonna
have Gronk at the end and then in about
15-20 minutes we're gonna have Dean
Jones rbr football insider from London
him and Sims talked about Sims as theory
will
and if L would NFL players if they
played soccer their entire lives be
better than Ronaldo and Messi yeah he
was great he was great it's phenomenal
any buttons his top button so it's hard
for me not so that like the guy he is
kind of I remember when we used to see
him when they were launching BR UK yes
and he would pop up there with his top
button buttoned and you're like I like
this guy he buttons a stop button yes
one thing I know you're not gonna like
what ACL epidemic yeah we're up to six
already who did I miss somebody have
this Lions fullback baudin and Vikings
rookie defensive end Hercules mata alpha
we are up to six ACLs already - ACL
epidemic sixes what did we get last
offseason do you remember it was like 32
32 minicamp I mean training for the
season started okay so okay six you got
room for 26 more somewhere in there
right it's usually between 26 and 32 you
know it's it's 90 guys all big all
strong all trying to impress all for the
most part mentally thinking by their
doing these type of things and that's
why it happens plus to the fact again I
will argue that in the NFL this day and
age the coaches are more worried about
doing walkthroughs in practice than they
are getting their players physically in
peak condition they actually play at
their highest level I think that's
what's being lost more than anything I
think it's a big reason for injuries to
rather not ramping them up they're
making them go right away go right away
right it's just not the way it was done
in the old days and I think that's why
you see more of these injuries now I
just got an alert from Bleacher Report
app that says a deal is very close
between the Cowboys and Zack Martin so
we know where that stuff that's good
some news always breaks right when we
get done our podcast on Wednesday yes
one of them being kind of noticed for a
while Earl Thomas is gonna hold out of
training camp right he released an
Instagram that said based on my
production over the last eight years I
feel as though I've earned the right for
this taking care of as soon as possible
with Earl
Thomas's play do you agree with him all
right so let's this is a great
conversation all right so yeah this is
different to me than like Julio Jones
Odell Beckham jr. Coelho Mac those guys
and and let's say let's just say leave
it at that Khalil Mac obj Aaron down
there on the roof
contract so let's let's go apples to
apples with Julio Jones a guy that's
been around the league almost the same
amount of time right
Julio seen a ton of money we know that
Earl seen a good amount of money my big
thing here with Julio and the difference
between what Earl Thomas is doing first
of all I believe that Julio Jones is
still in the conversation from one of
the top three receivers in football
right and you don't feel that way about
our lien I don't think you could say
that about Earl
I don't think realistically you can even
come close to saying that and that's I'm
trying not to disrespect the guy that's
in my through your top safeties I don't
know if he was in your top seven I don't
think he is and so that's right we're
gonna talk about this live and we'll go
through it like well just because he's
definitely not like top three for
anything like that now he's being paid
like he is the six highest-paid safety
in sport in football right the only guys
ahead of him Eric Barry Rashad Jones kam
chancellor Marcus Joyner Harrison Smith
he's number six he's counting as ten
million dollars against the the salary
cap this year right he's getting eight
point five at think somewhere base
salary all right NFC East alone let's
just start there I think your guy from
the Philadelphia Eagles Malcolm Jenkins
it's probably surpassed him by a jaw
hair either way I know Landon Collins is
better than him right so there's the AFC
East let's go to the NFC South the NFC
South I'm definitely taking Kineo I know
this is a strong saftey and he's a free
safety but Errol comes in the box and
candle goes back sometimes we're talking
about safeties in general so out of the
NFC South I think that's really I don't
think anyone the Saints no one on the
Panther right a lot of goods on the
Bucks nobody there okay now you go to
the NFC North okay some Smith Harrison
Smith certainly right the bears I don't
think there's anybody there Quinn Glover
Quinn I don't think so I'm gonna give
Earl the edge there in Green Bay as much
as I like that Josh Jones I'm not gonna
put him there yet either
right okay so then there's that all
right now we go to the NFC what do we
get the NFC West the NFC West you know
Joyner that would be the only guy in the
division I'm gonna put ahead of him yes
LaMarcus Joyner is really Tara Matthews
Kahn yes he's a younger Earl Thomas he
plays the position almost very similar
to the way Earl dust throws his body
around that kind of guy so yeah I'm
gonna play about McCourty on the Patriot
right
you're not are you gonna for I'm gonna
put Jamal Adams right from the Jets sure
right so that's the AFC's also I think
like guys like Micah Hyde are in the
conversation with all but I'm not even
out of respect for Earl let's say let's
give her the benefit of the doubt there
okay so we got Jamal and Devin McCourty
out of the AFC's that I'll take above
them right not gonna count Rashad I
don't think Rashad's quite as good and I
don't think we're gonna put Minka
Fitzpatrick in that category yeah now
you get to the AFC North I mean Eric
Weddle or I think Tony Jefferson is the
one there that's really the one that's
in that conversation very close between
him and her logic I would probably pick
Tony just because he's a little younger
and he's a little less wear and tear on
his body gotcha
right okay so there's that Cincinnati I
don't think anybody in that class Sean
Davis is maybe approaching that but not
quite there yet AFC South damn I'd
probably take both Jacksonville safeties
just to start there Barry Church into
Sean Gibson are awesome Wow
so there's that a church of hurl well
it's close there's a total different guy
but Barry Church is a player he said
he's a strong safety okay he's a huge
guy higher in Matthew I don't I'm going
it's close but I would probably take
Tyrone over him as well who did the
Titans get by or do you mean the all-pro
safety Riley had people ask him how you
feel
so he's really good so there's another
guy in that conversation then you get to
Eric Berry with the cheez-its right and
then maybe the rest of the AFC West I
don't know if there's anybody else there
Derwin weeds on the radar but not there
yeah I think that's it but so roughly
we're saying right there he's somewhere
between eight and twelve yeah
realistically right and he's a guy
that's smaller
he's 510 he's 205 pounds he's been hurt
a lot through the last two years this
guy that broke his leg two years ago and
said he might retire from football
does everybody forget that and all the
Dallas Cowboys locker room and said that
I would come get me so how would you
feel like the Seattle Seahawks you're
gonna feel warm and cozy and said oh
yeah Earl we'll throw you a bunch more
money on let's put our heads into the
head of John Schneider yeah kam
chancellor might not ever plague yes
does that make him more valuable it does
okay that's what that helps yes great
point yeah it seems as though Seattle's
resetting their entire
exactly do you want Earl to usher in the
new team that's the question that's the
million-dollar question I think that's
exactly that's where I was gonna go
that's where you're going if he doesn't
want to be there do you want him around
the new tee right but yet he's also that
guy that's mr. work ethic mr. detail to
where you go damn and he was here of our
glory days he can maybe show these you
knew young guys that are coming into the
system how it's done the right way
so that's where I find this conversation
fascinating because I don't think he has
a lot of ground to stand on to ask for
Seattle for more money now he might be
able to get more guaranteed money just
to set him up that way right but this is
different than the Julio situation where
Julio has believed as a top three guy
and is not being paid he's that he's
being paid like number seven or eight
and he should be you're looking at
Earl's getting six and he should be more
in the eleven twelve yes right so that's
goes back to what we've always talked to
yes players want to get paid for what
they've accomplished I know and the
teams want to pay them for their
potential yes and Earl is I don't want
to say out of potential he's on the
downslope of his career yeah this time
we're not trying to be mean it's a
thirty-year-old safety who's smaller and
been a awesome player and throwing his
body around like a madman is if you're
the team it's gonna be delicate of
course I mean very delicate if you're
the team and you really feel like okay
we'd like to keep him around because of
the reasons that we stated right that
he's a good locker room guy understands
the system does everything right then
you got to find a way three year
contract that's basically two years
worth of money that can be somewhat
respectable for both of you that's what
we need to know yes is what is Earl
looking for yes because if Earl's
looking for like top three money right
then Seattle's kind of facing one of
those and their secondary is so bad
right now no like the Seahawks could be
really bad next year it's it's
definitely big questions on the
defensive side of the ball it's it's
better be shot heimer and Russell and
Rashad Penny better get loose because
they're gonna they're gonna have to make
some magic I agree it's it's a
fascinating combo that one just to see
where it goes where do you think it ends
because the other caveat I throw into
this too is like to Seattle sign him to
a three-year extension that's
respectable money do they try to shop
him out
that to Dallas or some of those teams
and go okay now we can get something for
you maybe we'll shop you a little bit if
you want to go to Dallas so bad
tell your agent to call Jerry and figure
out a way to get you there it helps us
to we're not just gonna shop you off or
ship you out for nothing
it's just funny Seattle probably thought
they were getting rid of all the
stalkers the Richard Sherman's the
Michael Bennett's and moving on yeah and
heroes Earl go no no you still got to
pay me mm-hmm I watched all these other
new contracts all these other ups re ups
and all that stuff yeah you think by the
start of the season he's on the Seahawks
and do you think he's playing a female
have you made me bet I'm gonna say yes
and yes new deal and he's with the
Seahawks I've always thought that of all
of those players yeah Seattle fans liked
Earl Thomas the most I think so I feel
like it's him or I don't know I think
they're like the more than cam I do
think they liked him more they um I feel
like you would have a better feel of
than me cuz you're on social media more
I just feel like cam was the great
complementary piece to Earl yeah like I
feel like people viewed Earl just Earl
would always be the guy where I'd see a
video clip online of him chasing a guy
from 30 yards away and people be like no
one else can do that
Oh Earl I mean Earl the first time I saw
Earl it was on the field at Texas and
they were playing Alabama in the
national championship game and I new
world was gonna be a first-round pick
when I was sitting there watching him
but holy crap I mean Earl is a human
missile he's a special player in his
prime he is he's Hall Fame type safety I
mean that's what kind of player he is
I know it's interesting with them with
their defense I feel like there are
three Boy Scouts so the only one that
are still there Russell Wilson boy and
I'm talking by the defense or a Bobby
Wagner KJ Wright never really hear them
pop off bet everything right baby Wagner
only talks about himself not getting
respect maybe that's it but he never
causes problems with the team or
anything like that he always seemed to
be the guy in the sidelines trying to
calm down Richard Sherman or whatever
who's the third and C jet KJ right same
thing to I was the third gotcha guys
those three have always kind of been the
most teams yeah perception guys at least
Khalil max could hold out yeah how do
you think Gruden and Reggie McKenzie
handle this they're gonna sign him at
some point they're gonna have so much
money in Derek Carr Amari Cooper and
Khalil Mack yeah I know they are but
it feels worth every penny Khalil is I
mean he's in the conversation for the
best even supplier of the sport even if
I'd even seven be paid how quick until
Gruden is going out there and he's just
pissed that Khalil max not there and he
says something in the media that's
taking the room oh I don't think he'll
say something wrong to be taken by the
media the wrong way he's very smart
especially with star players he's gonna
realize a Clio Mac first of all he's
respected in the locker room and he
knows he's a good guy like truly a good
guy so he's gonna be careful about how
he attacks this situation this will be
one of those things I think it would be
the opposite Gruden will continue to
blow him through the media and just
hoping to keep everything good cuz he
hasn't had a lot of time around him yet
and I think that's one of those things
where Khalil and them figure out a deal
like the first week at training camp
because Gruden's gonna get he's gonna
get pissed off at a team he's gonna get
pissed off the Raiders he's gonna beat
my toys not here you know my big strong
my big strong muscular [ __ ] that looks
good off the bus I need him for us and
he's defense are exactly right because
Paul Gunther already came out and said
he's missing a ton yeah and I'm gonna be
like come on Paul come on what's so hard
about your defense oh my gosh Paul Oh
Coolio I'm third down put your hand in
the ground and go get the quarterback oh
that's how we taught it all year when
you weren't here Coolio goodness so
funny is like I talked to you about mini
camp and I realized it's all walked
through an elementary stuff yeah and the
coaches still feel as though they're
teaching Harvard Business School and
that these guys aren't gonna be able to
pick it up because they've never played
football it's the funniest I get in
conversations - this was like my coche
friends are in the draft every year
whether there's a receiver every year
that's here in four three two he's got
the fastest three cone drill in the
second-fastest 510 five I'm not sure if
he can run routes oh I know what route
are you gonna make most I mean I know
this great athlete the greatest athlete
we're seeing right now yeah I don't know
if he'll be able to go run to the ten
yard line and then make a left oh I
don't I don't know if they'll be able to
do that that was funny I sent you a clip
of Gruden and Brett Favre doing their QB
camp together as you watch it yes i-i've
never seen it I thought what was so
great was Brett was talking about how if
he yeah he worked on his own RP oh if he
wanted to create something new in the
offense he just did it
and then the coaches would go oh that
actually worked and he said in the video
if you ask a coach they're all gonna be
like oh this is how we've always done
not those toasters those are West Coast
like you talk about all the time and it
was funny cuz Gruden was just lapping
enough oh because he knows like yeah but
it goes to what we've always said yes
and the West Coast goes to young people
out there - yeah if you're at your job
now don't do anything to get in trouble
right but if you have a really good idea
show that it works and then pitch it to
your boss that's right if you go to your
boss and go I had this idea they're
gonna go another young idiot with an
idea just do it show that it works and
then show success don't show the
potential it's you know it's really
every industry it football is just very
slow very slow they just oh you got to
show me this plate ten times on video to
prove to me that it works okay coach
well the the first time this play was
invented was three weeks ago so there's
not ten clips of it yet but I have three
clips to show you three completions for
a hundred and twenty yards is that
enough yeah you know I mean it can be
like that Brett Favre he said it a few
weeks ago and I never really thought
about it until he said it when he goes I
invented the RPO and I first saw the
COFF Brett it's such a knucklehead and
then I sat and I've read the rest our
code and I was like you know what he
really did invent the RPO he did he was
the first one to be doing those kind of
things he get up to the line he'd go man
I know we're calling a run but these
corners are ten yards off ten yards off
if we're running right Rob receiver on
the left just run a one-step slam right
or just turn and look at me and there
you got nine guys in the box we can't
block this anyway so let me throw it to
you and you make a one on one moon and
then I love other video and then he goes
and nobody could tackle Donald Shriver
and that's that that goes back to like
our wide receiver discussions it's easy
to say and you've said this for a long
time that O'Dell can do everything but
there are guys like Jarvis Landry is
amazing at breaking tackle yes he is
that is a skill that he has Larry
Fitzgerald created breaking tack right
O'Dell good at breaking tacks
Antonio Brown good at breaking tackle
right Julio Jones great at three guys
you said it breaking tackles they all
got you know little legs and ass on them
to be able to expect that you're right
Antonio knodell are gonna be more based
on making you miss in a flag football
game right to an touch game that's what
they're really trying
embarrass you at their men's gonna cross
you over and you're gonna go what there
wasn't even a basketball yeah exactly so
we got two wide receivers Tori so we're
gonna get to our interview a Dean first
one happened right up to the podcast
Julian Edelman suspended and here's why
it's interesting it's an unknown
substance that is still being studied by
scientists to figure out what it is yeah
don't know how you get suspended when we
don't know what it is that seems a
little bit weird but it triggered the
test oh yeah but this is this is what
happens
and everybody was asking what your how
hot you're gonna get well I mean you
guys know how I feel I hate I don't like
this this is hey it's cheater Ville it
makes me question everything about
Julian and I questioned them before this
why because I just haven't seen a whole
lot of white receivers or white athletes
built like Julian Edelman with their
shirt off then when I saw him he was a
different level even from the West
Walkers and the Brandon snow Queens of
the world you were saying that when you
first saw Julian Edelman
I was then you cry was shocked at how
densely ripped he was for that kind of
guy and you were impressed extremely I
mean I was there the year that he took
over the starting job from Wes Welker
and I was in you know OTAs and training
camp but I was like man this kid is
lightning I mean he's he's better than
Wes Welker and he was outperforming Wes
it's a little dangerous when you look
back and you question it now after the
test or does the test allow you to
question well the test the test is
allows me to question it and it in and
Julian Edmund I know he works hard and
man I I like them I really like Julian
but yeah this makes me question and this
is what happens with cutting this is
what happens with cutting edge drugs
they don't know what they are people
didn't know what HGH was or some of the
other things they were finding in BALCO
until they exposed BALCO and then they
went back to test urine samples and they
said oh this is what this guy had in his
piss we couldn't figure it out man so
the drug industry's always a step ahead
of the testing industry are you going to
ever be able to look at Edelman's the
same or is this gonna be in the back of
your hallways back in my head really
yeah I can't I can't ever look at this
the same no this is again it's it's it's
the one saving grace I look at is the
fact that it did happen
after the injury right so well maybe he
was just to come back from this maybe
hopefully he was just doing to get
healthy but the questions still gonna be
there for me yes it's interesting if
it's just to get back from injury at
least there's like a motive and a reason
that kind of makes sense but it doesn't
make you think was it the whole time
this is what questions mean my last
thing about this cuz I know you're
looking at me like you talk too much not
at all but this is my other privacy not
interrupting this is looking hard my
other theory with Julian Edelman and
because I've had conversations with like
coach friends too in the past before
this because people have always marveled
about Julian a little bit because
players like Julian black or white slot
receivers when you're asked to be that
guy that he wasn't that offense so
dependable so many catches every game so
many routes run by contact they usually
wear out and cuz you're right in the
middle everything he was one of the few
I can always say but damn he looks like
he's faster January 9th and he was
September 9th and that was always a
little bit I think red flags for a lot
of people in football you're telling me
that people have been thinking this way
about the only that have Ben's been
there's a lot of people that yes there
they've been suspect of Julian Edelman I
thought the most telling part yeah was
that after it happened the first comment
was not from Julian Edelman the first
comment was not from his teammates yeah
the first comment was not for the
Patriots was it Alex Guerrero had a
comment ready to go yeah within an hour
yeah because he wasn't gonna get his ass
tonight
I've known Julian since his rookie year
he's a phenomenal athlete who takes his
training seriously it's disappointed
here today's news elite athletes
sometimes work with multiple coaches and
health professionals as part of their
offseason training he works with the
Patriots and he works with Guerrero yeah
who else is Julian Edelman working they
have other guys though see that's what
they do they separate so nobody knows
that Guerrero's first thing is right
I've known him for a long time this is
disappointing and the second line was he
probably works out with other people
right now I'm sitting there going I
gotta know who these are the people yeah
well I know that who else Julio's got to
protect his own turf right because the
New England mafia is gonna come after
them they
oh gosh this is probably the rarest of
all I'll tell you what right I wouldn't
be surprised if Brady told Guerrero and
come with a statement I wouldn't be
shocked because the first thing I
thought was if this was Guerrero Brady
screwed I would think I think you're
right Gronkowski's in that limited third
so it's gone Guerrero for him to be good
to the other guys he needs to make that
statement so I did ask Gronk and by the
way into the podcast Gronkowski
interview cool
brought to you by time but I applaud I
applaud that for him that and and but
this is what you've always said yes if
you're innocent speaker truth speak your
truth you know again Edelman apologized
right come on I've taken many many tests
over obviously over the course of my
career nothing like this has ever
happened yeah okay great but that's I
don't care about all that now I don't
know what happened come on come on
that's come on we know and that's what's
thinks about it and I think the other
thing I was just gonna say that's what
happens to Ryan Braun screw this up for
guys trained with trainers but then find
other guys to do their illegal stuff
because they don't want their trainer to
know that I'm mr. Johnnie hard-worker to
you you see me in this good light and I
keep making gains and I feel good about
it when I come to see you I'm just more
fascinated by the fact that I what other
players do you and your coaches friends
wonder about is that is that a dangerous
cane to play right now I feel like
everybody is nobody knows what to
believe anymore no Julian Edelman is one
of the guys that is just through years
of conversation here and there where
guys you know having a [ __ ] hey what do
you think he's on something like those
kind of things that happens a lot man
right right well it's like I said it's a
special build it's a special wiring
procedure there for again I'm not in it
for a white boy supreme I think the
thing that I've always looked at Julian
Edelman was the story of the multiple
sports yeah lead quarterback you know is
that versatile like compact slot guy
that I went his past playing career kind
of lends to someone like this but
durability is hard to question yeah it's
funny it's like I was thinking about
this when I was watching LeBron is there
another player that during the week we
celebrate how can you believe he hasn't
got hurt in 15 years but then when the
game starts and he holds his hand we go
oh he's milking an injury like
like so we we never really quit and
these questions come up for a LeBron is
LeBron on HGH are these questions and
and we just go no that's naturally his
body your point with Edelman is name
another person with his body that's my
point exactly
with that body that never wears down and
continues to get stronger as the year
goes at time that's all I'm saying
yeah there's maybe I'm wrong and I hope
I am I hope peak and Mudd the big test
for me will be to see what he looks like
when he plays this year not only to see
what he looks like as he's actually
running and moving but I want to see
what he looks like in the uniform you
know me I am gonna have my tough he's
coming off an ACL injury I don't I know
I know you're right it's not gonna be
totally the same guy yeah I get it it is
disappointing cuz you look none of us
want any of these athletes to get busted
no it's the worst it sucks it sucks I
look at it to now more than just
cheating but I look at it the fact of I
as a father look at it now that's where
it's even made me more harsh abit I
think about that as a father too because
I gotta explain to my son dad why is
number eleven suspended for four games
cuz he cheated son he cheated he just he
wasn't he didn't feel like he was good
enough himself so he took illegal drugs
to make himself better like I don't want
you had that explanation yeah I just
don't like to have those conversations
player did you have to explain the Filip
man the first one that came to my mind
was deflate gate a little bit I remember
having to explain that to him damn I got
to do this to him but no I don't know if
I've had to explain any steroids
instances quite yet yes you'd like yes
bring Phillip on the pot and have the
conversation chakras I'm here the other
wide receiver I want to talk about is T
Oh
Oh Terrell Owens right after our podcast
released a statement saying he was
humbled and overwhelmed about you know
finally getting into the Hall of Fame
but then said after visiting Ken earlier
this year I came to the realization that
I wish to celebrate what will be one of
the most memorable days of my life
elsewhere at a later date I will
announce where and when I will celebrate
my induction and boy did it upset people
we had a former columnist to the New
York Daily News Gary Myers say if I
would have known he wouldn't have shown
up I would have voted for somebody who
would have shown up Steve Young came out
recently I stopped before we go there
okay
let's go the media's right there Gary
Myers that's just it's not your job your
job is to vote on people who should be
in the Hall of Fame not to make some
stance on whether you think they're
gonna be there or not that's not what
we're asking you to do Gary Gary's a
good guy you're not your job is not to
add value this guy off the field or how
he treated you all I want to know was he
one of the greatest receivers of all
time and did he deserve to be in the
halls great point Gary so you're gonna
pick someone who's not as good because
he's going to show up to off to a server
right or not he's a little lunch so that
right off the bat I don't want to hear
that feeling you're gonna be agreeing on
this yeah I think so too
okay Steve Young yeah comes out and says
the relationship with the Hall of Fame
for him has been difficult because they
delayed his time getting in obviously
talking about tea oh I'm sure there's
resentment and scar tissue about it but
I beg him to reconsider
forget about Ahmed the voters I made the
system that damage that could be done by
not going could overwhelm him for a
period of time he said it could be
permanent so this is Steve Young who has
vouched for Terrell Owens for a long
time saying please come what do you
think about that well I that's great
that he's saying that I understand him
wanting the player the only thing I
would push back there is what damage
what like like what what what's the
damage is gonna be done I mean people
are talking about him the way they talk
about him anyways right I mean he's you
know the people who don't want to like
tio don't like him there's nothing that
can change it it doesn't see him like
yeah
so what damage and then are you telling
me like card company's gonna be like you
know we were gonna give you a hundred
thousand to sign Hall of Fame cards but
we're not now cuz you're not of the
ceremony no so it's not gonna do any
damage in fact I'm gonna argue the
opposite that it makes them more popular
now you're stealing my left well I think
that what's really funny is when this
happens people are never able to be
empathetic and to put their mind into
that person that for the last ten years
we have derided this human being as
selfish self-centered egotistical and
have taken shots for our benefit
for a decade if not more that he has
been one of the most beleaguered and
made to be evil people of all time right
we made this guy looked awful right and
who has been leading the charge I would
say it's probably been two groups at the
head number one media people media
people love taking shots at Terrell
Owens he's selfish teams wanted to run
away from him they're the ones that kept
him out of the Hall of Fame and you know
the other group that's probably been the
other derisive with him Hall of Famers
yeah
these old guys that just would come out
of the woodwork and be like I wouldn't
want tio on my team I don't know if I
want him on my team in the Hall of Fame
we're in the gold jacket and now this
guy's supposed to be excited to go to a
luncheon I thought about what is the
benefit of going for Terrell Owens yeah
the benefit of going is you get to be in
a room with all these people and they
shake your hand and tell you how great
you are and welcome to our family
well doesn't that just seem fake as hell
don't you feel like he'd go there and be
like all of you guys talked crap about
me and now I'm in and now you want to be
my best friend I don't think anyone
knows the reality of our media and our
sphere better than someone that's faced
it head-on and that's tio he's seen
everybody for their true colors the same
people that called him a scumbag are now
going to shake his hand and go let's
forget about all of it maybe he doesn't
want to forget about all of it maybe he
thinks it's fake that the biggest thing
that people are saying he's missing out
on is a luncheon you know Courtney that
is that's a lot to be there and you're
the main attraction it just I don't
think he needs to be over it yet because
I don't think that I think that some of
the members of the Hall of Fame and some
of the media members should apologize to
him and I don't think he's ever gonna
get that and I don't think people ever
think they need to apologize to they
think he still needs to apologize and
the true thing is it's supposed to be
about family and friends and loved ones
maybe he doesn't feel comfortable there
left go PR yeah I'm setting up if I'm
tio hmm the same day as the Hall of Fame
right
they give their speeches I'm giving my
speech and I'm working with somebody
like bleacher report or somebody like a
broadcaster and I'm gonna televise it -
all right because here's the deal yeah
of all the guys giving speeches and this
is an all-time year yeah who do you want
to hear from the most let's go back and
forth teo or Urlacher yeah yeah teo or
ray lewis yeah I still want to listen to
listen to you let's say I'm not the mood
for a 45-minute sermon yeah guy that I
don't think has great moral fiber in the
last two years has said a lot of
questionable [ __ ] okay I got you
tío or Brian Dawkins I'm the biggest
Brian Dawkins fan in the world and I
would vote for T oh listen - yes yes
because Brian Dawkins is he's gonna say
a speech that's gonna make me get
emotional right but for the population T
oh right t o or Randy Moss you know
that's the one and I'd still pick - you
probably would do Randy Moss has a
better accent yeah Randy Moss is good I
don't know what TOS going to say yes and
I think if tío broadcasted his speech at
the same time it might get better eh -
yeah it might be harder to find right
but I think would be more entertaining
I think Bleacher airport should get on
that actually we've cornered the market
so you agree with me I agree with you I
think on everything I mean yes I'm with
you man
yeah okay it's a special day he's been
mistreated by the media and the players
just like you've talked and know it's a
special day one of the best days of his
career why would he want to go like you
said go hang out with a bunch of
bouquets he's on a special day when he
can be somewhere with his family and
people that love him and that have
thought nice things about him for a long
long time and by the way Manas they're
worse people in the Hall of Fame other
than Terrell Owens I don't remember
people getting so angry about you know
Chris Carter or Michael Irvin who had
drug problems right but then for some
reason that was okay so that bothers me
along with the fact going back to the
Gary Myers thing right right going back
to what we've got kind of the Gary Myers
thing that's what bothers me about the
Hall of Fame more than anything this
power complex that's power given to the
media over this - where I don't know
where they got the right to dictate
people's future careers about how they
played on the field when most of them
are running articles while they were
playing and not really watching the game
of course that's what bothers me about
it more than anything you know again
I'll go back to my you know yes I'll
tell you why you feel that yeah when
your dad was playing yeah journalism and
media was real and they were the
arbiters they were the only ones that
could go to every game and watch every
game they were the only ones that talked
to the players now we're gonna get to
this in a little bit I mean we have
articles that are just about takes he
had opinions and cliques and so the
respect like like someone the other day
was like well that doesn't fit your
journalistic view and I went look I'm
not a journalist anymore I was like when
I worked for news organizations I was
I'm just a guy that talks right now and
I know the difference but I don't think
people do and a lot of these journalists
they don't act journalistically anymore
no it's it's a well you know listen
there's just not a lot of respect well I
mean the Brian Urlacher getting in on
first ballot and Terrell Owens having to
wait for third ballot does not make
sense
I forgot that like the last five years
of a lakor's career he was like number
one on the most overrated list voted on
by the players well I mean Urlacher I'll
say he is not saying he's deserving yeah
it was over he was overrated in the fact
that people thought he was a little
better than he actually was towards the
end of his career right there definitely
so many steps and yes he did but that
fact alone why cuz Urlacher was a nice
guy and a big media markt all that I
mean Terrell Owens is hands-down one of
the three greatest receivers of all time
nobody I don't think anybody's are gonna
argue that so that's where I just get
annoyed I get annoyed with the media's
power in the situation to where they can
dictate whether guys got in the Hall of
Fame or not I don't understand that I
don't nobody gets to write on the the
professional what why don't at least get
to vote on professional writers and
their Hall of Fame because I read I
write in fact I'm technically more
prepared to go to read job than they
they are in my job so that's what I
don't get here's my big metaphor yeah
for why I think it's okay for tio to do
this to me it sounds like the Hall of
Fame as a country club and they've
this guy that's been wanting to be a
member of their Country Club for a long
time and the members talk [ __ ] about him
in the newsletter and they never let
them play but they have a rule to
country club then if you win the public
tournament that you can get a membership
and then tio got the membership and they
said congratulations you've handled all
of our slings and arrows and you finally
made it and then tio goes I don't want
to be a part of your club I'm in take my
bust put it next to your busts and we're
all Hall of Famers I don't need the
luncheons I don't need the speeches I
don't need the hotel trips I don't need
the media requirements it's a great time
for the guys when you get to sit there
and like there's Terry Bradshaw on your
right and there's Dan Marino and your
left I'm sure it's great but if I'm the
guy that got [ __ ] on by all those I
don't need that to me it's just funny
it's just funny at the outrage if I if
communities they never wanted them no
exactly right a lot of them talk
negatively about him you're all the time
not really knowing him or the situation
two of the details just evaluating him
from the outside and what's going on I
bet you I could find 20 stories of Hall
of Famers taking shots at tea over the
last two hours I would not I doubt that
I'm not but couldn't you see like Lynn
Swann says tio needs to be more of a
teammate like I could just see it I
always think about if my dad gets
inducted the Hall of Fame I'll Kenny
Stabler style right post post after he
dies after he dies man I'm gonna show up
but I'm taking his head with me and walk
it off the stage like I gotta have
that's my dad yeah yeah I'd be pissed if
that happens I'll be will be pissed like
if that happens that way and I really
would I might steal his head and his
jacket and be like nah screw you Phil
Simms for the Hall of Fame
he was I mean a part of the giants like
run and then I don't know 25 years is
like the main broadcaster on CBS I just
thought I'm excited you're gonna steal
his head steal his head talking about
Hall of Famers Simms firmly believes
that if Odell Beckham or Julio Jones or
LeBron James for that matter
grew up in a culture where soccer or
football was king they would be a Hall
of Fame player and now we're gonna bring
in Dean Jones our BR football insider to
hash this whole thing out it has been a
debate that I have had to listen really
one-sided sim yeah we just introduced
this guy and say hello to him first
Jones you can find him on Twitter at
Dean's owns BR he is the big-time
football insider for bleacher report and
listen to this accent Dean how are you
my friend what he doesn't know anything
about football he speaks in that accent
so Dean I want to fill you in
Dean Dean is going to be covering the
world cup for Bleach report he's going
to Russia on Wednesday which are you
excited about going to Russia like I
don't even know I wouldn't even know
what to pack great me but I'm happy
about I'm happy to go there and see what
she was gonna see like so yeah I think
it's gonna be good fun I'm stocking some
Petersburg it seems to be a cool city so
why not would be this right yeah I mean
I'm excited for I made Dean I'm a cool a
soccer fan for the most part here okay -
so I've gotta lean on you for a lot of
information and just have a little World
Cup talk in general just you know first
of all I mean I'm dead serious I'm more
clueless than ever on this because
usually I don't it well yes you're right
it's not in the news at all so I don't
even know who the favorites are I mean
I'm sure Brazil and Spain are up there
Geneva but I yeah just break it down for
us as far as the team's you like this
year and the cons of stuff I just I'd
really like to know and just get it get
a little conversation here before we
start going at each other's throats Dean
[Laughter]
predicted Brazil right up there as a
favorite everyone's expecting to be
among the team's challenging to win it
Brazil Germany Spain and France it looks
like it will be one of those four but
Argentina just behind them if things
don't really go to plan but Argentina's
so heavily reliant on Lionel Messi and
then you've got obviously Portugal and
the Cristiano Ronaldo factor they're a
bit further taking order but we
someone like Ronaldo on board you can
never completely write them off so it's
going to be an interesting tournament
because there's not one outstanding came
that you're like really expecting to win
it could come from one of four really
and if it really opens up then 106 do
fir for the novices like me and the
people that are listening on our podcast
that I'm sure aren't like diehard
football fans or soccer fans for your
money right now who is the best
footballer in the world right now that
question again I just want to make sure
if it was still down to those two I
didn't know if a Neymar got in that
discussion now or somebody else that I
didn't know about but it's so it's too
close to it but you still have to look
at her now don't mess here I mean I'm
the way I kind of describe it is that
Messi is the best footballer in the
world because in terms of natural talent
in terms of the way that he runs with
the football because of the things that
he could do you literally can't not
teach the way that that guy runs he is
the best footballer in the world
Cristiano Ronaldo has taken himself to a
level that you didn't really expect him
ever to get to he worked harder than you
could ever ever imagine to put himself
in that same bracket as Messi he
probably wasn't you know when they were
younger off starting out their careers
Ronaldo wouldn't have looked the same
player as message even though he was
still very good but I've got a lot of
respect for the fact that he is work
countless hours to getting to this level
right in terms of as a footballer I
played the messages just slightly good
judgment
okay uh-oh here comes left oh here comes
the first bomb of the interview in this
corner Chris Sims is arguing that NFL
players if they played football their
entire lives would be better than Lionel
Messi and Cristiano Ronaldo he says
people like Odell Beckham jr. would be
better in this other corner Dean Jones I
have no idea what he's going to say but
I think
gonna call Sims Daisy and let's get your
theory okay gosh this is makes us a lot
harder when I got a say to this to
someone that knows a lot about this
sport we can fight back against me I'm
ready
so again this is I have respect for
soccer players and football players I
don't want that to be lost in
translation here okay I really do know
the messies that Renaldo's the old
Ronaldo the Neymar's I clearly see their
physical gifts that I understand they
are topped to your athletes of the world
my big argument is the fact that
football yes footballers in America and
we took our top players or even I would
argue too in this argument of which I
don't know maybe we go a step further
here where I always say if Americans
their best athletes play NBA or NFL NBA
or NFL players let's say if our best
athletes played soccer let's say from
the age or 9 I just feel that that's all
they play and that's all they played
that I feel that if we put on the field
Odell Beckham jr. Julio Jones Tyree kill
Braun Jay you know LeBron James and we
had Kevin Durant at goalie that we would
be pretty tough to stop because these
are some of the most explosive people on
the planet ala there are 40 times their
vertical jumps all that stuff so that's
where I argue and push back against you
oh oh great soccer Oracle please push
back on me now what do you think I'm
sure you've heard that before Dean I
haven't actually heard it before I think
that the big issue with it really is
that in you know NBA NFL the size of the
Gaian yes they're so huge like that
wouldn't really translate into the sport
you know there's not many huge
footballers that have been successful at
the elite level so I think that's going
to be a problem if you look at guys like
LeBron and stuff they're six for a Kevin
Durant I think you need six foot nine
you know you don't get elite level
football that's all no I would I would
say you're right there because I would
want them a goalie I don't know if they
have the quickness of feet and things
like you're thinking more these 511 the
Odell Beckham jr. who's 511
and does have at least we've seen some
of his footwork with route running and
things like that that's where I go it
could be very interesting yeah I think
that there's certainly an argument to be
made in terms of bullying prowess but I
think that I mean I do Beckham I think
is one of the players that did play
soccer when he was younger and actually
yes kind of gave that up once he got
some kind of ten eleven years old and
kind of took the other route went to the
other football and I have quite a lot
with kids over there in the faces that
they do all play soccer at a very young
age right and then they kind of taken
away from it I'm not sure whether it's
because they actually don't have that
same passion for it at other sports but
whatever the reason nobody thinks to
really persist at it it's a culture
thing I think Dean yeah obviously
exactly it must be the culture Odell
Beckham I've seen actually he did a
thing with Bayern Munich once now so
I've seen him kick a football and he can
kick it but I wouldn't say he was ever
going to be like Cristiano Ronaldo even
if he practiced every day how dare you
well one question translated NFL and NBA
skills into our football or soccer is
that your sport is it's so based around
short bursts or set plays and right so
much for a her thing goes into it they
your guys are so intelligent to take on
so much information and in a split
second decide which clay they're going
to make and run it and that isn't that
that really happen in our game you know
you you'll you might have a corner kick
that you work on but you don't do you
have like three routines that you need
to know and the same with a free kick
you know you have all these did this
book of players that you've got to go
through so I think that in terms of
intelligence then there probably is
something in your athletes that L don't
so much need but then there's also the
flip of that is you've got to get
through a 90 minute game without without
stopping you're not getting coach every
yes there's no commercial break is that
right I like I say no from an endurance
perspective yes soccer guys we talked
about this read
only NFL guys you run in six seconds
right
soccer guys you don't stop running it's
certain Oh tits it is it's a good car
it's a different kind of shape it's a
different kind of running either I would
like to think that the Renaldo's of the
world if he trained on short bursts he
could be really he could be even faster
I'm down and I also would like to think
that the Odell Beckham jr. 's of the
world if they had to be more endurance
based they could write it's truly a
nature versus nurture it is a little bit
here's the athletes and the NFL in the
NBA are in terms of all the measurables
better athletes right but the argument I
always hear from the football side is
these guys grew up in a culture where
it's ingrained in them from birth yeah
you can't teach that anyway III hear
that do you agree with that yeah I mean
that's totally true I think that you
know I spend quite a lot of time in the
States my wife's American I've seen
around people that like L football but
they they talk about it in a completely
different way to how it's understood
here and I see some MLS teams like la SC
and they start up a team and they have
their perception of what good what it is
to be a good fan is running into the
stadium and it does look cool but it's
all set up and rehearsed and whereas in
Europe in South America is just passion
and it is inside of you and I think that
that's the one thing that you'd have to
have ingrained in you but I mean America
you've got you're a melting pot so
you've got enough different cultures to
call upon I think that that's you know
the American national team for football
should be better because I think that
the amount of people you've got out
there who do love the game you're just
not calling upon enough of them to play
it I mean your college system and the
facilities that you've got there's
nothing else like that in the world in
Europe you know I go to college and play
alpha or I'm literally playing in a
field in front of three people and a man
walking his dog you know I'm not playing
in a stadium I'm not I'm not getting
that kind of thing you're having to go
to the actual clubs and there are
categories to get anything like that so
and then actually yet there's a kind of
missed opportunity right now because
you're right you have brilliant athletes
and
so many American athletes have an
incredible mindset where they believe
that they are the best there's an
attitude of being an American is very
unlike anywhere else in the world where
believe you set your mind to it you can
be the best it's a good thing and a bad
thing in our country like in the
positives from it
ya could produce better footballers but
I just don't think there's enough out
there that want to be because they'd
rather be an NBA NFL player yeah I think
that's a lot to do with it Dean I'm
fascinated by this like yeah just your
overall you kind of just said it your
overall view but what is it like just
even your your fellow countrymen just
them what's their overall view of
American soccer and do they does it does
the world even really want America to
get good at soccer I mean maybe the
world is just sick of hearing about
America in general and anything so
they're just glad they get a break from
that word during soccer it's people are
taking it more seriously now you've had
some big names there now and you just
signed less honey for him a [ __ ] over
there LA Galaxy and that's a big name so
it makes people watch it I still think
that the thing that people struggle to
get their head around is the facts with
it you have the guy like that's one of
the biggest stars in the world learned
huge amounts of money it could be
playing alongside a guy who kind of
$40,000 a year and there's nowhere near
the kind of level was left in years I
think that while back it's hard for
people to take it seriously because it
it's just not like anywhere any other
leagues that we have here they're
they're professional leagues where
everybody is everybody in the team is
pretty much the same level I think
that's the big adjustment that people
have to take when they watch MLS but as
a result of that misbalance if you like
the game with much more exciting
sometimes you get some big score lines
and is on our TV here you know the main
broadcasters do show the games and
definitely more people are talking about
it and watching it so I think it's going
to take somebody like Cristiano Ronaldo
to come back I think right right left
hands one thing but you know Ronaldo I
actually wrote a piece from complete
report earlier in the year
about the fact that he wants to end his
career over there and even Miami or LA
and that's you just that happened you
know that that's when that's when
perhaps you do get guys that we're going
to be thinking of being NFL players
thinking actually maybe I'll stick with
soccer because the guy like Ronaldo is
the kind of role model you need you know
that's probably the other issue with why
you haven't had a superstar football
year is because it's not really been the
role model there's been people like
David Beckham and stuff like that but if
for now though was they're still you
know kind of in his prime if he was to
come in two years I would still be in
great shape and I think people would
really relate to that yes what about
American football in England
I'm just curious you've actually we hear
all these stories
oh they're selling out Wembley oh yeah
maybe they're gonna move a franchise
from your litmus test where is England
in terms of accepting the NFL it's crazy
they sell out seconds as much as here
you you really can't get a ticket and I
think that certainly in London where I'm
based everyone is kind of getting used
to NFL that it's still a slight problem
in terms of when the games are played
and getting them onto a very Tony
brilliant so you know Sunday's you can
you can see it but you're not going to
see everything but getting dedicated
fans over here now more and more of them
I mean obviously I work at bleacher
report so I probably hear more about it
than the average person on the street
but it wouldn't surprise me at all if a
franchise moved over here because every
single game would be sold out people
would buy the jerseys and all the rest
of the merchandise is it genuine like is
it genuine interest or is it more like
this is happening and I want to see what
it is or do you think there's people
that actually have always liked the NFL
I think there's a mixture I think that
there's definitely been a hard call
always like the NFL who has heard of
people like me
they just did it wasn't on very often it
was kind of like a late-night highlight
show it's only in the last few years
pretty much every game if you want to
and I think that people love hike you
know and like I said they're about now
they came over to play in America
suddenly you might care about
want to know more about this guy it's
the same here suddenly you have some of
those personalities actually on our
doorstep if they were in your face every
day and you were hearing about their
funny story that you're seeing their
show rules every day you're going to be
more interested so I think that it's
it's on our screens more so people are
playing more attention certainly the
players are more recognized than they
would have been five years ago and yeah
you know seriously if someone like
Jacksonville ends up moving over to to
London and playing at Wembley or it's
not them or anywhere else then I think
that people would buy into it straight
away Dean I think your your point first
of all about like if we could give
Ronaldo came over here somewhat in his
prime I think that's a little take for
some of our you know let's say you know
those young kids that we go he's a
superior athlete if they could see that
that can make you gravitate like that's
what I think is gonna have to happen for
soccer in America like that number one
high school recruit in football or
basketball switches over to soccer
that's gonna open up eyes to where some
people are gonna go whoa I think it's a
combination of that and they need to get
one of those crazy salary per week do
exactly that show the financial what
they're getting it yes when somebody can
speak move you're like what's that while
they earning up two hundred thousand
pounds a week 300 by if they're getting
your bank every week people start to
perceive it but you know you've got
Christian people are sick at the moment
who's kind of like the closest you've
got in a while to having yeah an elite
player if you like you that first year
Dortmund he's been watched by a lot of
big teams but the problem with him it
he'd had to leave America to go for
serious dream Germany a young agent I
kind of kept the coaching in me so you
just need the whole infrastructure to be
around those players as well because you
know USA they've got some good young
players in the national team at the
moment they just need to all be in the
same page and for the next generation to
already be right behind them right all
right so wait more importantly are you
still buttoning your top button yes okay
good right now we're your football UK
I'm football America we button our top
okay so
this bump there okay other thing you
dean do you get [ __ ] for it too because
a lot of people give sims crap for
buttoning his tab button so doing it you
don't really get that here know like
people quite like it
so like I'm not the only person around
London that does that MC people do it
now though I think it's definitely
becoming less cool so I'm having to
think sometimes I'm going to look around
and see if I am the only one I look a
little older the fight last thing for me
that I just mind faceting and I thought
about it only because I saw your Twitter
page but for those out there who don't
know you're out you're on your Twitter
page with Ronald Deano Ronaldinho excuse
me please
have you met his both his new newly
acquired wives by any chances how do you
think he's gonna do balancing out he's
married to women last week what had the
same thing he did no idea
oh you think he denied it yeah but it's
funny we as part of your gig I was on we
went and we met on our do you know on a
rooftop in Vietnam I think it was you
know he turned up and he's everything
you'd expect on a dino to be he's flashy
he's always smiling he wasn't too
interested in what we actually wanted to
play football he was just interesting
everything around it and there was there
you know if you've been in slowing
there's a few girls floating around and
I think you'd they cool is I think more
the type does the game when people just
allow just love even talking about him
so when I posted that picture on my
Twitter you know went mad this because
people got so much love room yeah yeah
it's amazing I mean I loved watching
them play but what I what I heard he was
gonna try to marry two wives in the same
ceremony wow this guy's got some talent
here to balance that Dean Jones all
Simms and left go faithful do me a favor
as the World Cup gets going Dean Jones
be our hit him up on Twitter I'll be out
there in Russia being one of the
football insiders for bleacher report
cover in the World Cup Dean you are the
man
and keep button in that top button and
we appreciate you pal okay
I've enjoyed that YouTube thanks Dan
Dean be good man all right thanks again
to Dean for joining us
love the accent love the top button the
man we talked a lot about what happens
if American players or big-time athletes
start playing soccer and can they get
the money I'm starting to see a trend
that I didn't think would happen Kyler
Murray the the Oklahoma quarterback
that's going to be a replacing Baker
Mayfield right he was taken nine from
the MLB Draft couldn't believe the team
that took him was willing to give them
money add to let him play one more year
of college support could be that but
then another kid Jordan Adams four star
football player four or five star
basketball player taken seventeenth in
the MLB Draft he's going to play
baseball we saw this was like drew
Henson a guy that went played baseball
for a little bit and then came back
right but is there any chance that this
generation of parents younger parents
been hearing their entire lives the
contracts in baseball better the
contracts in baseball are better could
guys be going to the baseball's and the
soccers and leaving the basketballs and
the footballs I do think so
I know that you're trying to get your
son well I hope so I sure the hell hope
he plays baseball or basketball I don't
think I think basketball is gonna bear
the fruits of this NFL conundrum to I
don't think as much no I think that you
got to be that six seven six eight guy
and that's a lot rarer there's six two
guys there's no doubt yeah you're a
different sport it's a different animal
for the basketball world it's truly a
special built individual so you're right
you go to those games you go I where did
you come yeah exactly
so so but yes I think as a whole what
you're talking about I do think sports
like soccer sports like baseball parents
are pushing them that way because of the
fear of football and what it might bring
I see it in my own you know town that I
live in and here the parents talking
with the kids and all that you know
parents are just so scared right now to
let their kids play contact football and
what the ramifications to that can be so
I do get it and the door is open right
now for some of these sports
to capitalize on the NFL whether it's
the anthem policy the concussion policy
all those things to take advantage of it
and kind of swing the pendulum a little
bit 2021 man 2021 the two new football
leagues are gonna start XFL the other
one a AFL yeah I'm sorry if I'm
pronouncing it right you're right
and then all these other sports and
NFL's man it's gonna be interested it's
gonna be yes and it's gonna be great
yeah all right it's time for a while
whoa big offseason first one that I'm
gonna show is the Chris Sims the guy
that he absolutely got right out of the
draft last year Carl Lawson some video
of him practicing I'm gonna put this on
the YouTube as well Carl Lawson
blindfolded taking hits from an
offensive lineman and just kind of
working on his hands and the question
that I asked you Sims is I don't
understand the point of him being
blindfolded Wow
I mean first of all his arms and back
and chest and shoulders holy crap
the point of being blindfolded is that
the fact that you can't when you're
rushing the quarterback you can't see
everybody's hands you got to be able to
go off a feel at times and just go and
be able to hey you're playing the
Pittsburgh Steelers I'm Carl Lawson I'm
coming off the edge damn where is that
levee on bail I'm trying to watch levy
on bail but this big freakin Villanueva
keeps putting his hands on my shoulder
whatever so he's learning to have the
feel to fight off this without having to
have his eyes on the target it's gonna
teach him basically yeah just body's
awareness of space and feeling the
context so he can keep his eyes focused
on something else all I know is he
didn't practice with knives so I'm not
really that interested once you get to
air and I am he has thick holy crap
though his upper body here's what's
funny when I realized when you look at
NFL players I don't know what is big for
an NFL player I assume all of them are
big right so he was big enough in the
upper body to garner your attention yes
he was the like I mean I mean look at
his damn shoulder and PEC and arm and
back part here holy his lat is bigger
than your quad yeah it's it's
unbelievable and I wonder why you lasted
to the fourth round
that's insane another whoa big offseason
this is really a no big offseason
there was an article in the Detroit Free
Press now Patricia in danger of losing
his players and this thing said that
this guy's main observation Carlos
menorahs and I'm telling you right now
Sims and left go loyal listeners I'm
never reading another article from this
guy again like any news or whatever I'm
just not trusting it because this is
insane that the rookie coach
Patricia wants things done his way and a
lot of punishment that means a lot of
running and he wrote that's not likely
to endear him to his players many of
whom are experienced professionals who
don't need to be treated like junior
varsity tryout players this is my
favorite part even former coaches like
jim schwartz and jim caldwell didn't
punish players with running very often
touring mini camp or training camp yeah
because those jim schwartz impaul dwell
errors were so incredible that that's
what we needed in detroit was to do the
same game plan the New England Patriots
run their players more than anybody else
and yet you are complaining about
running the players because you think
the vets are gonna think it's child XP
me and the experienced pros he's talking
about he's you mean the experienced pros
who haven't experienced winning number
one right having one [ __ ] but they're
gonna tell you how to do it right
so yeah you said it might've n that's
right it's unreal it is it's it's so not
part of the culture in the NFL because
you do it in in high school our practice
is over we got to run gassers coach is
gonna make us run gassers and college
you don't do it very much right so then
you get to the NFL and of course it's a
full-time job and you're in shape
throughout most of the year but pyres
are never quite as in good a shape as
they think they are and Bill Belichick
has taken that upon himself to make sure
that they are and that they're one of
the only they were the only team I was
ever on or ever around that what
practice is over and we have to run
gassers like what are you kidding me
that was the only team I was ever about
Josh McDaniels or when I was working for
New England watching and it's a culture
shock and it's a little militaristic a
little which they're not used to right
and what else do we talk about I've told
you about you know Brady in this
quarterback Center exchange they could
fumble a snap right
bill just goes run and everybody looks
up but he just goes just [ __ ] run and
the offense has to run around the
goalposts and run all the way back and
then run the place if there are players
that are there bitching their moaning
they're not ready to quit yet they
realize they haven't done anything and
they realize this guy's coming in from a
place now they're not happy you can't
lose anybody no they're not gonna lose
anybody specially with a guy like Matt
Patricia everything that I've heard from
the NFL you lose people when you leave
work early you lose people when you
don't address situations head-on you
lose people when you realize that you're
not a leader or you don't work hard
enough getting work too much these guys
are going like their mother [ __ ] them
when they come off the field like god
damn it's torture Matt can't believe
making us run like this but they're not
like this guy's cool is he's an idiot
I'm not losing than anymore no it's more
of like competitive anger at this point
with a guy like this it's they're not
used to this and there trust me hey
Detroit buckle up players because you
got more to come that you ain't used to
it's it's gonna be a different training
camp here at a Bill O'Brien and you know
simply here obviously with Belichick all
right let's continue whoa whoa big
offseason again you can get the new whoa
big offseason shirt @bi te ly / big
offseason we do not put whoa in there
because everyone spells whoa differently
how do you spell whoa WH o eh yeah some
people spell at whao whao
yeah no Wow yeah and I would say that we
have a new leader in the clubhouse for
biggest whoa team the New York Giants
for the first time have four whoa big
off seasons in the same week wow this is
incredible Wow first one say Quan
getting praise from Brandon Jacobs
Tyrone Wheatley and Rodney Hampton just
the New York giant great running back
from an abbey like he's the man he's got
it whoa all season that's great yeah
next one have they seen him in person
yeah yeah they went and saw him okay I
just wanted to make sure I actually have
some quotes now man Rodney Hampton man
that's brings back some memories
yeah man big old Rodney that's funny
though well he's one of those guys that
I would imagine even for top level
running backs like that they saw him
move a few times and they were probably
whoa yes big legs big movement yeah like
Brandon Jacobs came out and said hey
open up the playbook tremendously
Brandon Jacobs first time I ever saw him
in the field the year I lost my spleen
we had to go up and play the Giants I
was hurt I was on the sidelines here and
got pushed into our sideline like ii
play the game after running off the edge
and I was like man we're losing this
game we ain't nobody gonna tackle this
guy that's insane he was enormous
enormous I couldn't imagine that was one
day where I looked at it was like man
I'm glad I'm not playing defense will
Hernandez has already gotten into five
fights whoa big all season and Eli
Manning's response I love it yeah I bet
here's what's even better
Will's response iron sharpens iron
that's all we're doing getting each
other better we're all competitors out
there sometimes we're gonna butt heads I
don't go out the intention look at me
you can do it I just go out there and if
it happens it happens it does iron
sharpens I like that it's the way he
plays I could see that he would be a guy
you'd pick I would go I bet you he gets
in a few fights during training yeah
there's a fight happen at training camp
it just guys are tired they're angry
they're been blocking the same guy and
they're sick of blocking the guy he
might know some of their moves are you
gotten the best of me three days in a
row and I've had enough and my coach is
making fun of me now yeah and all of
those things just bottle up to where ya
frustrations boil over it's never
personal I've never really seen anything
be taken after that I think the only the
reason happens is you're literally
punching each other in every day so
eventually you're gonna get upset the
guy that's punching you exactly and out
of the fact that it's like the 20th day
in a row and you're hungry and tired and
haven't been sleeping in your bed at
home ya haven't gotten any of your wife
or girlfriends booty in a while although
you're back down whoa big offseason
Giants legends say that the Giants
wasted Eli's prime I heard Shawn O'Hara
to be honest with you they wasted the
last few years of Eli's career it's been
hard to watch Justin Tuck we know that
when he's healthy he can do things with
comparable athletes around them and I
don't think he's had those anything
other than that you're just lying to
yourself did the Giants waste Eli's
prime of course not I mean why is this
still a thing
why are we so I mean what are people
gonna say what's Shawn O'Hara gonna say
I don't know that he's not I know it's
not right that he brought that up that's
really not it because it's it's it's
it's I don't want to sit here and say
it's wrong but it's wrong I don't know
the Mannings prime end I would say 2012
I was gonna say 13 yeah I mean right
around there right so he has had dismal
play for four years yeah some of it's
been McAdoo right but I mean one of
those years he threw for like forty five
hundred yards that's why they kept bad
McAdoo there so again Eli's really good
but this day and age he's not really
good
he's down towards the bottom of starting
quarterbacks in football he is the
biggest question on the New York Giants
now they they have a few years of
turmoil there the last few years with
McAdoo and the transition from coffin to
McAdoo sure but damn the nine years
before that we're almost I mean just
couldn't be the more perfect roster
around the quarterback I mean that's the
thing is that's like they can have
weapons around him that's it's just so
erroneous that's where I got annoyed
with the statement I wanted to go all
right forget about like really when you
name through it and you go let's just
running backs it's been Tiki Barber you
know you just had a bridge it was Ahmad
Bradshaw okay there hasn't been much
else but yeah like the three drivers
shot Jennings owes but nothing great
okay but the o-line the all the way up
until 2013 was really tops in the NFL it
was phenomenal
he had Plex ago Burris who was without a
doubt one of the five best receivers in
football when he was there with the New
York Giants people forget Steve Smith
was one of the best receivers in
football before he tore his ACL shock
he's been there Martellus Bennett has
been there sterling Shepard Odell
Beckham jr.
Hakeem Nicks Mario Manningham been
nothing but talent around him now the
last few years you know they haven't
been
is good okay but I would also push back
the year they were 11 and 5 they went 11
and 5 in spite of Eli Manning not
because of him I mean it was every game
I could do year yeah the year they went
11 of 5 they beat the Cowboys twice
right lost in the boat game to the
Packers out there you know the Packer
game was the best game either I played
all year and he played one good half
right and he was a few drops but he won
every game that you're like 10-7 Landon
Collins pick sixes break in nine tackles
Odell Beckham jr. running 70 yard
touchdowns so yeah I push got back
against it and no for me as Phil Simms
sorry everybody's gonna go oh you didn't
either I'm Manning hater no why can't we
just keep it real I don't give a [ __ ]
about who my dad is or who Eli Manning
is that's just the way it is sorry
is it because Eli is such a good guy I
think part of it yes and because
everybody is he's actually agree as a
great guy he is funny he's everything
that you think Peyton Manning is Eli
actually exactly is what it sounds like
exactly right I'm right yes you're right
yes I think is I mean I've never hung
out with either no I think I think
people think if I was to be fair people
as a personal level like Eli more than
they like Peyton right I mean belies a
really good dude
just because he's a good dude here
doesn't mean I'm gonna sit here and lie
to you and go oh he's a top 10
quarterback because he's nice to me in
the parking lot sometimes that's what I
hate about this job that's where
everybody gets conflicted like no he's
making 30 million dollars a year if he
can't handle some [ __ ] like me
telling him he's not that good then I
don't know what else to say it is
interesting it is it's a narrative
that's been pushed up here by the Eli
supporters I would even bet it's from
the Manning camp to a degree all of it
it's not a good old line he's had no
help it's also like how are the guys
like Eli's performances and the Super
Bowls and those throws yeah there were
many guys that were on those teams how
could they ever speak badly about him
right I mean to have that throw to David
Tyree and finishing the blacks ago and
the throw to Mario Manningham like yeah
if I was on those teams I would be loyal
for life right but we have been saying
now for three to four years it's over
yeah and look I know that Shermer once
Eli because he wants the vet but it's uh
it'll be interesting yeah well I be
forget those teams underperform so it
was awesome like yeah in 2011 they went
nine and seven and won the Super Bowl
you know two thousand two thousand
eleven they went nine isn't 2007 they
went ten and six you know he made magic
happen recently ly during those years
yeah I mean people forgot 2007 there was
a point during that year where people
are going this might have to be the end
for Eli man and we don't know if he
could be the quarterback up here in New
York then they won the Super Bowl and I
backed everybody off yes so I don't know
what happens interesting is all these
other guys also said the running backs
that I saw interviewed and the other
guys this team has a chance to go twelve
and four yeah there's a lot of
excitement there's a lot of anticipation
here if there's a lot of weapons yeah
you have Nate's older at left tackle you
have all those weapons that we've talked
about so many times it's going to be
clear at the same point
Eli might put up four thousand yards
yeah III he goes an offensive
coordinator he's got all those weapons
on the line he could yeah well he's the
big question that's all we're saying
he's the big question and he certainly
could he could go I don't even think
this is that shocking no it shouldn't be
I don't know but the biggest whoa big
offseason yes of the entire Giants Davis
Webb we've talked about him a few times
he's got the strongest arm in camp and
you said well who is he going up against
well Letta and Eli right there was an
article I didn't see this blew me away
our guy Matt printed out the article and
underlined all of his favorite parts and
I read it and I was dying because it was
there was like six whoa big offseason
moments the article was titled Davis
Webb will be ready when it's time to
step out of li Manning shadow already
kid hasn't taken a regular-season snap
but he's ready to go first thing article
starts off arm strength quote I can
throw it better than anybody I have a
great arm my arm strength is probably
too strong apparently he regularly tells
Odell Beckham jr. that he could out
throw him no matter what BAM
okay I've never heard anybody say that
about themselves I mean I never even
heard Aaron Rodgers say that you say
that about yourself oh I do have a great
arm but not during like I oppose so
let's read that clover my forearm
strength is probably
two strong arms I never said that though
it's too strong I'm gonna break in with
my arm bleach report okay
Cowboys make sack Martin NFL's
highest-paid card Wow awesome let's see
what that is I got my stuff up here so
me looks record guaranteed money six
years 66
oh no Andrew nor well it appears the
Cowboys have surpassed Andrew nor Wells
numbers which was 66 and a half over
five thirteen point three in guarantees
right thirteen point three average
basically so Wow
Zack Martin's gonna get somewhere in the
14 to 15 million dollar-a-year average
is what he should he's better than
Andrew Norwell he's the newest guy to
get the new contract and he's been the
best guard in football since he entered
the enough happy for a second closer all
right now back to Davis next big about
himself
keep going well I mean a backup
quarterback saying I throw it too hard
and Odell Beckham arm is probably too
strong yes like a second sentence in the
article yes he does have a strong arm I
don't think it was as strong as Patrick
Moore Holmes in his own draft class but
okay we're on his own team remember he
used to be on Texas Tech and left exact
as Patrick mahomes was the guy exactly
music he has an office playlist he has a
home playlist he has seven different
playlists for seven different days of
the week but he's excited because he
believes that when him and Manning are
spending long hours that quarterbacks
room he has a he's introduced Manning to
six new bands so he's he's the one young
and up he'll I'm Anika whoa
their relationship is so good that Eli
calls him dragon that's where dragon
comes from they don't they don't
announce why worker Davis Webb is
obsessed with printing out screenshots
from film studies statistics and news
reports quotes anything he finds
interesting and he files them in
three-ring binders he estimates that
right now he has about 25 binders each
with around 200 pages of stuff inside of
course he has an Eli Manning binder for
keeping track of everything he says
Davis Webb has binders whoa big boss
season last year Webb put together a
scouting report on the tea
next opponent each totaling hundreds of
pages and he would present them to
Manning on Monday
most of the scouting report should be
handwritten no it's hundreds of pages
I've never got a scouting report that's
hundreds of pages in fact if I got a
scouting report those 100 pages I'd go
[ __ ] the scouting report I'm not reading
this you just print this out yeah he
also was the first Giants player to get
a printer in his own room that's how
much he likes to print damn Davis you
went to cow tree hugger school if you
haven't heard stop wasting trees and
printing crap out okay he would hand
write a lot on my own spider you had a
computer that has memory well you got a
three binders you know I like printing I
know you do
yeah but handwritten notes from film
breakdown and copious research and he
would give so he would give them to Eli
that was a great one apparently he's at
the office so late I can't take it do
you see how many whoa big office is
ridiculous I feel like this is like this
is my favorite one FoxNews over here
with Trump homeless I know better than
the coach's music I got all the musics I
have all the music last year a Texas
transplant transplant in New York Davis
Webb decided to buy a Tesla sports car
for the summer combined with this
predilection for wearing capri pants
Manning made fun of him every day but
this year Davis Webb is back to driving
his pickup truck in all-black 2018 Ford
f150 lariat the other night went out to
dinner in midtown Manhattan with a few
teammates who were all wearing Jordans
Webb had his cowboy boots back on quote
I'm back I'm back to my roots whoa Davis
where was this article I think it's on
the SPM this is a QB this is the kind of
article that's gonna get him just
lambaste it in a locker room I mean he's
gonna get because everybody's gonna go
let me see these three under page
scouting reports there he's gonna get
lamb basted for all this it's a lot of
hockey the whole
a lot of us mmm Cuba I apologize all
right either way mmm that was a lot of I
that that will open eyes within the
Giants it's very funny we talked about
Patrick mahomes yes not wanting to take
any advertisements in Kansas City
because he wasn't the guy and now we're
already starting like the Davis Webb is
gonna replace Eli Manning story grab
Kowski heard listen to the podcast he
got a big kick out of me talking about
him and the commercial you know I told
ya he was like you know be listen to
this Sims and left go he turned it on
and he said we were talking about it so
it's pretty good man but no Davis Webb
sounds like he's raring to go
they they were telling I'm excited I
mean I am I'm excited for pre-season yes
let me just see him out there exactly
3:30 potential it could be the guy he
could he does have a lot of the things
you'd look at and go okay I I you know
funny enough I remember seeing him on
the field him and Baker Mayfield oddly
enough when I have a neighbor at Texas
Tech together but how does this make you
feel oh it's I think this is an epic
woebegone that's an epic one right there
I've never seen a young quarterback who
hasn't done crap talked that highly
about himself
is that that one right there that's
unbelievable it is yeah I'm curious to
see him in in preseason and all that
stuff I'm do you how do you think he
lied takes to all this oh I don't think
you like Kara Co he's unflappable he's
so comfortable I think in where he's at
in his career and everything like that
it's nothing the only guy that I think
has been this cocky having not done
anything Johnny Manziel and we have a a
listener that hit me up on I think hit
up the the podcast yeah
Conor O'Neill and he asked if he can be
our Johnny Manziel reporter he said he's
going to go to every game and he's gonna
give reports so he had a preseason game
against Montreal on Saturday and Conor
O'Neill sent scouting reports I'm
talking about he charted every single
play series 1 series 2 Series 3 and he
went through first Johnny Manziel let me
give you information he is backing up
Jeremiah Masoli
or
legend up there when the regular season
begins this upcoming Saturday quote
coach June Jones says you saw him out
there he's still a little rusty
he finished stats with 12 of 24 88 yards
and one touchdown Connor I'm gonna kind
of go through one part of your notes
here in summary and he said while he did
make strides towards improvement he said
he was learning a lot about the
positions because apparently CFL is
different there's a lot more space he
made strides towards improvement he is
still noticeably trying to get
comfortable with the offense and schemes
he only took two deep downfield shots in
his 20 attempts and most of his
completions were shorter check down
throws swing screens and short throws
designed to stretch the zone then he
looked it kind of sounded like he did
pretty good but he having a lot of
strugglers and he wouldn't be shocked as
he mends all the starter in the back
half of the season okay but sounds like
he's gonna be fighting for his job I
think that's the thing I've jumped out
to me I mean I know June Jones has said
Mzoli's the starter told otherwise told
but the the thing that I've noticed out
of the two preseason games is yes what
our guy there Connor said and Connor I
think the summaries is what we would
like on a weekly basis give that to us
Connor and the other thing too is yes
lack of throwing down the field I've yet
to see that in both games and even
though there's a AFL thing so I need to
see that a little bit because that was
one of the reasons you were so high on
Manziel in the beginning yeah was the
dude could rip it when he needed he can
he can throw the ball I remember you
would you could tell I'm sure Kyle's
getting frustrated on Brian Hoyer
because there's a number of deep throws
that Manziel could make that whole year
can't yes wrath but we haven't seen that
yeah we have not seen that yet and yet
Manziel has the mentality to be an
aggressive down the field thrower but
you know you're not comfortable
sometimes you just want to okay I'm
gonna run the system take the easy
completion continue to learn not exposed
myself with some dumb mistake whatever
it may be but I do need to see that at
some point I need to see some consistent
20-yard in cuts comebacks things like
that
to tell me where he is physically
because I haven't been blown away by the
throwing as of yet like I
look at it on the film and go or on
highlights and go wow that looks real
speck Connor also said he's mainly going
up against second and third teamer okay
so we haven't even seen him against the
number ones yes all I know is there was
one clip of him scrambling out and
making a throw that a lot of people
shared and the only thing I took away
was that de closed on him real quick so
we got a long way to go we do we do all
right so I'm gonna toss to Gronk and
we'll be back after this but let me just
kind of give you a little insight on how
I did the Gronkowski interview I am NOT
a fan of interviewing people over the
phone it's not something I enjoy I
really don't enjoy interviewing
Gronkowski over the phone main reason
and Simms you know this when he well he
will not talk about other players on
other teams he is not going to say a lot
about guys on his team and he usually
gives one-word answers but last time I
interviewed him I said these these last
few are from fans and he perked up and
he went oh I like fan questions so I
just pretended that all of my questions
were from fans what a liar
Patriots boy 12 pack QT 19 I got the
whole list you'll hear him as I go
through but some good moments here is my
sit down on the set of a tide commercial
my fun interview with Rob Gronkowski
hello hello what's up what is that bro
how are you men good how are you I'm
amazing my name is Adam luff Co welcome
to Sims and Lefko we are now joined by
the greatest tight end to ever lace up
them cleats Rob Gronkowski how you
feeling Rob good man
feeling good all right so good I went
online and I talked to the fans and I
said I gotta I could ask him all these
real football questions or I could turn
it over to the fans and let them ask you
questions does that sound good yeah
sounds good perfect
again brought to you by tide first
question Sam Levy he's going right to
beer krob how quick can you shotgun a
beer in seconds if we time this at the
combine I can tell you this when I saw
Tom do it on the shows like two months
ago he absolutely destroys everyone with
it and I am not that quick
at pounding on so I'm actually pretty
slow and another guy that's super quick
is Julian so I would have to give that
one the Julian and Tom as the top
jugglers and I'll be probably like third
or so behind I was in a couple of
seconds so that's not my forte okay so
so Rob comes in third on the Patriots
second question this one is from JM or
Luna speaking of Tom what does Tom Brady
smell like unicorns rainbows I would say
some tide pots he smells like smells
like the best tide pods
he smells like fresh Tide Pods I love
whatever he stinky I take him out when I
gonna add them at his locker
you just throw right at him yep I love
it
alright third question this one is from
Seahawk scout when you went you came and
you saw the team did anyone make you say
whoa big offseason so Seahawks cow tasks
you walk into the locker room and did
did you see anyone and they kind of got
bigger over the summer you went whoa big
offseason I mean I'm not even really
sure what kind of question they're
trying to really get to I know it's
Seahawks always a big just just put it
this way it's always a big offseason mmm
there is no non woes it's always whoa
big offseason
yep that's what it's always like that's
awesome
all right this one comes from go Pat's
go seven eight one do you like being
called Grunk ah yes I do
I don't mind you at all I mean people
that personally know me usually don't
call me by that but I did not mind it
one single bit what do people that know
you call you Rob Rob so shop should I
call you rob or Gronkowski what woods
what should I go with yeah either are
don't matter okay this one comes in from
Pats cutie 19
have you seen say Kwan Barclays legs and
ass yet uh-huh yes I have
and I see no my you know I've seen him
play before seen him uh at the combine
in staffing
I like definitely do look Beasley got to
give him you got to give him credit
there have you heard his nickname people
are called him say quads no I never
heard that yet but I would probably say
so it's pretty good all right so then
Pat's cutie 19 followed it up with who
are the best legs and asked you've ever
played with on the Patriots
I gotta go with our Vince Wilfork oh
yeah he had some legs huh yeah exactly
this one comes from throat al Beckham
are you upset about Edelman um he's a
great player and a great teammate to
have and unfortunate situation but he'll
bounce right back yeah of course all
right so this one comes from Vinny
cherry which i think is a play off
finitary do you think if NFL players
played soccer from the time they were
born
could they be better than the guys in
the World Cup I don't think so
nope how come it just takes a lot of
training a lot of love for the game and
obviously we have more passion to play
the game of football and soccer I guess
not really sure I just feel like they're
so skilled that that's why we stuck with
football oh okay I see what you're
saying all right then this is the last
one from salt and Julius pepper have you
if let me read this hold on where is it
okay there it is
have you thought of a name for a kid
like if you had a kid have you already
thought about some names you'd like to
name be Roberto Roberto Gronkowski yeah
I like that I want to call my I want to
call a daughter Dawkins but you would go
with Roberto what about for a girl I'm
not sure never thought of that one yet
but I have thought about Roberto all
right so I need I need the the Robert
Gronkowski right after a spike what
would you say to all the tide pod haters
out there what would you really say tit
to get that back on board
what would I say yeah I would just like
to show them how effective my cranks
bike is so my crank spikes that
effective then it shows how effective
type odds are as a laundry detergent to
so those two things are equal they're
equal they got that much power all to
him
damn so what we've learned about Tide
Pods today
Grunk you throw them at Tom Brady and
they're just as powerful as your spikes
it's pretty good [ __ ] yeah it is I like
that I got one more actually from Billy
Barkin it's a comment and it says please
don't get traded that was all it says
that one just came in Tom thank you and
you're gonna appreciate it Rob I
appreciate you my friend have a great
weekend dude oh man you kill so there it
is Sims if Rob Gronkowski had a child he
would call him Roberto so Roberto
Gronkowski that would be hilarious and
when I asked him if he if he knew what
he would call a girl he said not him
Roberto Roberto Gronkowski I enjoyed
watching crown get the horse race first
of all I didn't see it oh my gosh well
Gronk came in second yes but he wasn't
sure that's the best part of it you got
to watch the video of him watching the
race okay because when they make the
turn of course he's really excited he's
in 2nd then he thinks he's catching
justify and he doesn't realize this the
race is over like they're in there like
they've already crossed the line but
he's way down I think he caught him well
you can see him mouth like where's the
line oh my god hilarious but that's
really fun he's awesome and I'm glad
justify 1 that was awesome I enjoyed
watching that I didn't I didn't watch it
I've already talked to you I've already
told you
Triple Crowns nonsense now now that now
that American Pharoah won I'm not
interested oh my gosh you're ridiculous
I'm doing things at 5 o'clock on a
Saturday it was at 650 and you're not
that busy so relax I was busy
guys thank you as always bi t dot ly /
big offseason whoa
big offseason certs shirts are here and
they're here to stay I want to say thank
you to all of the people that send me
dozens if not hundreds of whoa big
offseason moments over the weekend
throughout the week you guys are awesome
thank you to everybody on the reddit
page I need to get back on there more
I'm definitely putting some stuff
YouTube commenters figure out Phil Simms
phone number
let's get Phil Simms in the hall of fame
for Chris Simms he's at homies ventric
would say green and the lef koe man says
preciate you love you and we'll be back
in a few days we're gonna have Florio
and Phil Simms on Wednesdays show should
be it going can I say that yeah alright
you better [ __ ]